thank you
all right Balaji it's good to see you
again hello good to see you I think last
time I saw you in Florida it was about a
year ago and you welcomed me to Budapest
he said come on over to Hungary and
here we are thank you very much for
visiting us I hope you enjoyed the
weather well I mean the weather is
incredible The View obviously from up
here is incredible uh people will
probably hear a little Construction in
the background we are sitting uh right
across now from the old Red Cross
building which is under construction and
I thought that would be a nice way to
start the interview because there is a
lot of construction going on here I mean
this is this is an old city that is to
me feeling a bit like a new city so
there's something interesting going on
here
yes I I would add two things one is that
you know it's a construction is always a
sign of economic success so in general
if you have construction sites all over
you
you know probably they don't like them
for for a short period of time but for a
longer period of time it's like it's
like shows the economic strengths of a
country and I'm happy to see that here
in Budapest is uh and all around Hungary
something is doing and the other part is
the Reconstruction of the so-called
Buddha Castle Hill
and which was uh actually demolished in
the second world war it was bombed by
the Russians and then before they was
used as a as a for military operation by
the Nazis and then the Hungarian
companies who obviously occupied the
country they also did some serious
damage and these
usually
classical or wonderful architecture
style buildings and and we
we made the decision to to rebuild them
um it's like there is a governmental
program so if you come back in two years
time you will see the entire custody of
fully recovered everything is rebuilding
in beautiful classical architectural
style it's it's it's it's still the bad
it's not right now today is the one of
the best places of Europe but it's gonna
be really really gorgeous yeah and as
you know I am coming here after a nine
day trip to Israel and one of the things
that I found there is there they're
constantly in this battle between old
and tradition and new and technology and
everything else it seems like something
similar is happening here that you guys
are trying to look back at your past
figure out the good parts to bring to
the future but then also govern in a in
a somewhat sensible way which is pretty
rare for the West at the moment you're
not anymore talking about architecture
we're not talking about our well we can
if you want are they going to be putting
up some some Modern buildings here oh
actually but term but you know this is
from the architecture of debate you can
understand me actually everything
because what we are doing here is that
we try to restore everything which made
Hungary great in the in the past and we
it's it's part of our heritage if we are
not proud of that then then what makes
us hungarians what is the purpose of our
life so this is important part and the
other part is you will see in the city
some other
um modern buildings which were which
were created by foreigners very famous
Architects from all over the world I
think it's it gives us Pride as well to
bring them to Hungary and let them to to
to work here and we are fighting against
the
the modern concrete and glass I'm just
just jerk like just like like nothing
special type of buildings if there is
something Hungarian in that obviously it
has to be a high quality thing but has
to add some some tiny little Hungarian
thing in in in that this is this is how
things are going to work and not only in
in just architecture and reconstruction
but but like policy making yeah people
you see things like that how do you
think those things are connected like
architecture and and actually City Life
and and physically what you're looking
at to the to the political side of
things I think that you know to figure
out what the people want and what makes
be a good government it's not so hard
obviously you can learn about this for
like years in universities but but you
you get the point very very easy like
like people want safe and beautiful
environment around them people want a
very supportive environment around them
a state which helps them to raise their
kids to to to make a family to have jobs
they want secure streets they don't want
garbage all around everywhere they want
companies which are which are producing
high quality Goods so it's so simple and
and you are having good government if
you if you see that things
slowly unfortunately but going to that
direction if you look back
retrospectively it's obvious then where
you were right 10 years ago and what did
you achieve since then and if you see
the this kind of progress not the
progressive ideology then then then you
fear that something good is happening if
not then you have to change course
because otherwise you're going down what
do you think the secret to the success
of that has been in Hungary now
obviously you're a rough you're a fairly
small country population wise only about
10 million people so there's a there's
an ability it seems to me to direct
those people in a certain way where from
an American perspective 350 million
people it's harder to herd those cats
and and get them to see that we're
seeing it at the state level since I've
been here we've talked a lot about
Florida you know it's that's working uh
but at but the national project seems to
be struggling
I I think the the most important thing
that you have to be sure and make sure
that the people dress with voters are
behind you and then it doesn't matter
whether the media is going against you
whether the big corporations are going
against you in our case as a small
country International Organization ngos
um and and like like Brussels is going
against us but but if the people are
backing what we are doing then we are
fine this will be always the last round
here uh the last you know just just
space to stand do you find the people
like that actually that the the people
support you more when Brussels comes
after you or if if you take a a say an
immigration policy that obviously is
counter to what the EU is doing that
sort of thing honestly Among Us I don't
understand why they are doing that
because the more pressure they put on us
the more popular we are getting Hungary
because it's so obvious yeah I mean what
happened in 2000 15 400 people
made the decision to march across the
country without any kind of permission
it's like it's like it's like not good
it's it's against the idea of Law and
Order people want to have uh Law and
Order so they said that they support the
government to to stop it and and since
we have the attacks they support the
government even more yeah
it's actually not the controversial
issue politically in Hungary also if you
ask the the leftist opposition voters
whether they support stricter
immigration policy they there as it
would be yes so what what is going on
with the left here uh it seems to me
that maybe it's not quite as radical as
our left is that is that fair to say
I've asked a few people that over the
last day or so and I'm getting I'm
getting various it they want to be they
want to be there well that means they're
not so it's probably pretty good yeah
well I you know I we were talking about
it I think the general environment
it it does matter so and and uh this is
this is the reason why the
responsibility of the media it's it's
big so I mean it's like politics is one
issue party political debates are part
of the Democracy it's like it's not
about that but but there is a common
there should be at least a common
understanding
um that for example you do not support
any kind of violation
um
at all and and and and the media should
not support that this was full stop this
is this is based on common sense not not
based on party political uh ideas and in
Hungary I think the the media and even
some serious opposition parties they
they take it seriously because they see
if they go to another Direction then
then the voters they will punish them
and they will not not support them
anymore they were looking for other
Alternatives they probably they will not
vote for for that right but they were
looking for New Alternatives on the left
do you sense that I'm happy to
experience that yeah no I wish I wish we
had a little bit more of that with our
left it would help it would help me
bring balance radicalization you have to
somehow be able to stop it yeah it's
interesting because from an American
perspective our left they can have
different policies obviously but there's
something else where they're they're
angry at the founding of the nation
they're angry at the laws of the nation
that strikes me as much more dangerous
where that's that's that's the thing
when when we start talking about
um
when we start talking about the lgbtq
and the gender issues yeah and um the
pope was here two weeks ago CPAC was
here one week one week ago actually
since the pope was here that's uh when
we have since then we have the good
weather yeah yeah well then he did
something right he did something yeah
and um and
everybody was very clear on that that
this kind of gender ideology it's it's
very dangerous because it it it divides
the nation so it it wants to override
the idea of nationhood and of that all
the people it doesn't matter what color
they have how old are they where are
they from they belong to the same nation
and there is more thing which unites
them than than than
brings them separately so and if if you
let these ideologies emerge then then at
the end of the day sooner or later it
takes years but but it will destroy
everything which brings the people
together and then it will be very hard
to to to maintain and to manage even the
most
basic functions of the society yeah it
was interesting because when I when I
spoke last night I mentioned how you
know there should be a separation
between the LG and B and T that the T
thing is actually anti-lg and B and it's
anti-women and and it got a nice round
of applause which I was happy to hear
from a conservative audience because I
think that that's an important part to
note true but but like like
like but also in a migration issue and
and with the
in general with the sexual minority
issues obviously
it discrimination is not acceptable
because we are the same Society of all
our human beings any kind of sexual
discrimination is is unacceptable you
know what we are doing in Hungary is we
try to focus on on on what things are
bringing together people the the wealthy
people The Not So wealthy people the
young people the old people people
coming from different parts of the
country and and you have to put a lot of
energy into convincing the society that
it's worth to keep together if we have
National purposes then then we have to
um you know keep United yeah I think
this is this is what I learned from the
United States this is how your wonderful
country became the most successful
country on earth right and interestingly
I mean my the purpose of this trip for
me was to figure out how do I import
maybe what is going on here back into
the United States because we seem to
have lost a lot of that what would be
your main message I mean you've been to
the United States by time you were
actually in Florida just a couple weeks
ago I mean when when you see some of
what's going on there what would be your
main message on on how to fix some of
this stuff now first of all
first of all we know our place so it's
it's still a small small country far
away from the United States after many
centuries of suffering so and how you
know is The Mouse and the air sure
so I I don't think that it should be
pureed but but our experience is that
that um
people want to fix their life and people
want to fix their their country so and
and it's not impossible to bring them
together and be United
especially in a democracy democracy is
still the best form uh to do so and and
all politicians who want to restore uh
American greatness or do something
against what is going on right now there
should be aware of the fact that if the
people are behind you you have to
convince them to be on board with you
and then you have will have the chance
to to bring change and do you basically
just ignore all of the noise I mean the
prime minister's office is literally
about 30 feet that way I don't think
he's in the building at the moment uh
but you know when I when I tweet that
I'm coming here or I retweet you I get a
certain amount of oh it's fascist and
they're mean and blah blah blah and I
look at it and then I just keep meeting
Pleasant people and seeing what's
actually happening on the ground I mean
do you just do you just basically ignore
the noise and just go ahead
I would be surprised
if if they were supporting me so that
would cause us no problem
if the media is supporting you that yeah
that's what the Santa says also
yeah well it was a pleasure seeing you
again and I look forward to uh to
exploring just this absolutely inquiry
tell me tell me what yeah give me one
thing that we should do if we have a
little fresh start today right here
absolutely stunning yeah it's a it's a
gorgeous gorgeous thing but uh
each it's it's about Hungarian
sovereignty because it was built more
than
120 30 years ago and back at that time
there was a competition Among The
Architects that what kind of building
should be should be built and um and
there was a commission which made the
final decision and as you see this is
this is the only neogortical style of
building in town all the other ones are
just now neoclassical ones uh buildings
and
back at that time the commission was
saying that
it cannot happen that the Hungarian
Parliament building will have the same
architectural style as the Vienna
government buildings because they were
never renaissance building so that's the
reason why they went to that direction
because they wanted to have an
independent a different a sovereign
decision so they were choosing this this
kind of neogortical architecture science
there are no other buildings with this
style in the country this is the only
one and this is this is like even 130
years ago the most important thing for
Hungarian people was sovereignty how
they
differentiate
the hungarians from uh from Vienna which
was the headquarter of the Empire back
at that time so it's if you come to
Hungary you will see a lot of tiny
little signs people for like 1 000 year
or even more fighting for their
sovereignty and this is if you see the
result this is a this is a fight which
was to be continued
and on the continuing path you will also
see a lot of cranes because there's a
lot of new things going up so that that
proves it right there right is the
Basilica which is the main Church the
Parliament building and the soccer
stadium
this is the triangle it was great to see
you my friend very nice to see you if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell